hey y'all
movie retrospective time once again this
is the movie that
uh again you know in the patreon poll
uh won by a landslide that's not because
the other movies only got like one or
two votes this one got like a whole
shit-ton
this is the 2000 canadian werewolf movie
gingersnaps i liked this movie you had
never seen this no
i never saw it as busy at the time that
it came out busy i was busy being like
these kids
[Laughter]
i've been out of the army for a few
years and uh started falling in with my
ex-wife and all her friends and they
were a bunch of goth girls that looked
they just [ __ ] looked like that and
kind of act like that kind of dressed
like that and it just
the music and everything just the way
these things looked it just kind of took
me back took me back to that
yeah there was a lot of uh the music in
this i think fear factory was in there
raised in black had a song i think
cradle of filth might have had a song in
it
um [ __ ] like that which was you know
that wasn't really my thing but yeah
these are high school students you know
my
my wife and her friends weren't that old
but some of them were only a couple
years out of high school
i felt kind of like the han solo of the
group because i was in my late 20s that
from that from their point of view i was
like the old guy you were like almost
like an old wise guy
or a world weary you know this thing
like justin croft's boy you know you
might run through a star
i was like doing that you know yeah yeah
it's just funny because um i think the
first thing you said when we started
watching this was that it was like
taking you back to this time period
like late 90s early 2000s late 90s
because the thing is i mean i graduated
from high school in 1990 so
by this this was like already 10 years
on and like i said i'd already been into
goth like
way back in the 80s so to me i didn't i
have to say
i think i've probably mentioned this on
the show before i'm not a fan
of a lot of the late 90s teen horror
that came i like scream uh and the
sequels to scream are actually pretty
good too
but the other movies that kind of came
in the wake of that
um you know like i know what you did
last summer and like all those kind of
movies
they're okay but i just wasn't a big fan
of the teen horror
genre like in the late 80s that said
i guess you could kind of put this in
that category
but this one was actually a lot
different and actually a lot better
it was a lot more culturally accurate
you know like those girls that were
taking pictures of themselves these
dramatic pictures look like crime scene
photos and i love that because that
looks like some [ __ ] we would have done
but it was more like you know rising up
out of the grave
in the graveyard you know and [ __ ] you
know it's all that [ __ ] funny [ __ ] we
used to do yeah
the girls used to do that it was [ __ ]
great they'd show me the photos and i
was like yeah
that's good but there was there was the
very beginnings of the internet you'd
[ __ ] scan them on an expensive
scanner back then
put them up on your myspace page or not
myspace did they even have
my spaces it was second um
web tv page yeah i don't even know if
they had myspace in 2000. i remember
having myspace in maybe
2003. or something like that that wasn't
my space i kind of feel like observing
we were putting them up on web tv
that's pretty funny yeah people the
girls were scanning them at work
and then they were sending them in
emails to your web tv account and they
were putting them up
web tv kind of had the first during this
era
web tv kind of had the first thing that
was like myspace yeah
and it was a web tv user
pages well i think aol had that too they
had it too but you had to have
a whole pc right and in this era most
people only had access to a pc at work
yeah that's you know young people didn't
have two thousand bucks to throw
on a on a pc for home use
you know so a lot of the cool [ __ ] that
we were doing online was actually done
where the girls were working like like
uh
primitive photoshop and effects and
stuff and then you mail them to your
at that time web tv account and then
jimmy it around then he started to come
up with weird prodigy stuff which is
just a laptop and a
and a keyboard and you had an account it
was kind of like web tv but it was
more sophisticated as remember that
thing i think it was a project we didn't
have that
i remember the name but i don't i think
it was a prodigy machine
or something you know it had a dedicated
i mean we had a windows computer like
probably in 98
i think we got our first one i had yeah
i had a gateway computer
yeah we had it was gateway like gateway
gateway 2000
in the 90s but for some reason or
another it got it got lost in i was
moving around and i sold it
that kind of deal you know i think so i
think
i think my stepdad gave it to me as a
gift and it quickly became
obsolete but we're getting off track no
but yeah so uh again this is i would i
would even
hazard to say that this is easily one of
the best
werewolf movies easily top ten
i mean i mean they're i'm saying there's
not a lot of werewolf movies that have
been made
and there's and of the werewolf movies
that have been made they haven't made a
lot of good ones
you know what this never occurred to me
before but i was watching like some
other [ __ ] about
ginger snaps and somebody said that the
reason that there aren't as many
werewolf movies as there are say like
vampire movies or zombie movies or
something like that is because a
werewolf movie
is hard to do on a low budget because
you have to have a transformation scene
you have to have a realistic looking
werewolf and if you don't have that
then your movie's not going to be any
good so i can see why like from a
budgetary point of view why there aren't
that many
yeah i wouldn't put this like on the
part of like the howling or anything
well no no but i'm just saying that it's
up there it's up there but
but the the emphasis is diff is
different they get bit
it takes them a long time to slowly
become a vampire most of the movie is
that slow kind of transformation the
weird [ __ ] that happens during that time
and they're almost kind of like a
vampire during that transformation
part you know what i mean it's in the
very end you see some
aware wolf fight but it's not a whole
movie of it
yeah it's kind of more concerned with
the transformation
like the slow burn transformation and
it's also very obviously
um making the parallel between ginger's
werewolfery and her puberty you know
what i mean
which isn't that's not the first time
that a werewolf movie has been
used that way i think teen wolf you know
with michael j fox in the 80s
he did that too but interestingly i
think
this might be the only one that was done
with girls
and the weird thing about it this is
another thing that never occurred to me
until i was watching this other video
about it
was that if you look in the history of
horror cinema
there really aren't a lot of female
werewolves period i mean you know what i
mean even those like
it's they're like it's almost it seems
like a male thing they're like when
there's a woman that changes into
something like a were animal it's almost
always a cat
like a big cat um just because i guess
cats are seen as more feminine
i suppose uh than wolves are so i think
this might have been like the first one
for sure the big the
the first like well-known one that
actually used
female puberty female sexuality and
stuff like that to explore and use the
werewolf myth to
explore that um so i thought that was
kind of interesting as well
and i have to say that i love i had seen
this movie a couple times interestingly
here's another thing i didn't know
because i said it was canadian
it played in canadian theaters i don't
and please correct me if i'm wrong but
i'm pretty sure
it wasn't released theatrically in the
united states
i think it was released in some other
countries
like it did pretty well i think it only
cost four and a half five million
dollars to make
it um so i'm pretty sure it did make its
money back and they've actually made two
sequels to it like uh gingersnaps2
obviously
and then there was one a third one
called gingersnaps back
that i think was a prequel except it was
kind of like
it was the same two actresses but in
the 1600s except it was almost like a
remake of it except it was
in the 1600s you know what i mean yeah
i'd like to see him i have never seen
him the second one i
i don't think i've ever seen the second
one the second one gets like a lot of
mixed reviews because they
they did like continue the story with
bridget who was you know ginger's sister
and they continued with the whole monks
hood thing you know what i mean like the
plant that they you know boiled down and
they made like a werewolf care out of it
but in the second one i think they're
positing that it doesn't work or it's
not completely effective
so bridgette who uh you know got
who got turned into a werewolf at the
end of the first one um or at least had
mixed her blood with ginger's blood
and uh you would presume that she would
have taken the cure but
i guess in the second one they're saying
that you know it didn't work i just wish
i would have seen this in 2000
yeah it was one of those ones that kind
of like it like i said i don't think it
was theatrical but when it came out on
video like it started getting
like a lot of word of mouth and occult
following i'm wondering if
i had seen this in 2000 whether or not i
would have approved of it back then
would i have just seen it as just like
everything else
or what i've said now that's kind of fit
you know i look at it now
look look him back on it i go man that
is a very
culturally accurate movie about the way
we were back then
yeah that's the way it was yeah and they
they captured it perfectly
a lot of the movies that are kind of
about the goth scene and
the young people youth scene that you
want to put in the utes the youth scene
of the late 90s they get it all wrong it
was wrong even back then
you look at you're gonna that's those
are fake teenagers that we didn't do
that it was that kind of [ __ ] yeah
another one that was really accurate was
gypsy 83
oh man i love that movie we need to
review that sometime too yeah
and there's a story i got a story about
that movie
the kid in that movie the gay kid in
that yeah i remember
you know what it is a friend of mine
ex-wives oh okay it's based on it's
based on him
uh although in real life that kid died
and he's not in the movie
he can't my dad not my dad my girlfriend
or my ex-wife was um uh a pen pal with
him
yeah uh connor before a lot of that
stuff happened
in in gypsy 83 yeah um
because he was out in the country by
himself and just remember how we used to
goths used to have the [ __ ] pen pal
rings yeah yeah and all that
so she was writing to him that way okay
and um
she saw his name in the credits
afterwards when they were rolling it
well actually melissa saw the names in
the credit and called her and said do
you realize that that's
i think his name his real name is dylan
i think yeah really that's about dylan
and she freaked out over it i need to
see that movie again yeah i remember
really really liking that because i saw
that a couple times
yeah that story kind of happened
evidently in that movie but that
happened like after my ex-wife
was writing to him after she knew him
yeah all right but anyway
most movies about these
this that subculture are highly
inaccurate but this movie gets it down
to even the [ __ ] clothes
the [ __ ] black knee socks with the
big heavy [ __ ] the
old hot coppers yeah all right what the
hell we might have to [ __ ] edit some
of this
yeah edit this a bit i actually said my
dad for some reason because i was
talking about mississippi
um another one that they got right was
remember when she started to transform
into the
into the uh the werewolf she had the
jacket and the skirt
yeah the boots and everything the way
her hair was done that was exactly the
way
goth girls from that era
looked in that year and a few years
before that
with the exception with she was wearing
more brown earth tones to
to be more like a werewolf yeah the goth
girls was all black and gray and white
to look more
vampiric yeah but it was that's those
same kind of furry looking little
jackets and the
same boots yeah i remember that does
that scene the same hair with the
colored stripes in it it was just
perfect for that era and that's that's
how it looked
and and seeing it reminds me of how good
it looked
yeah it's that's about time for that
look to come back it looked really good
you could get away with wearing that
nowadays yeah i don't think anybody
would look sideways at you no
it's not it's not crazy looking no yeah
it looked good it was real feminine
looking but not
not like uh frilly and that not kind of
a frilly way it was kind of sleek and
feminine looking i liked it yeah it
looks good
which like i said i think that's like a
really good yeah encapsulation of
her becoming a werewolf yeah because
okay so if
in case you don't know i don't know why
anybody wouldn't know this
because i feel like gingersnaps is one
that a lot of people have seen
um you know because it's it comes up
like every best werewolf movie
list that you want to name it's you know
easily comes up on there
so basically it's about two sisters um
you know ginger and
bridget now ginger is supposed to she's
a little bit older i think she's gonna
turn 16 or she's just turned 16 and her
sister is uh
15. and one thing i like about this the
actresses are slightly older than their
counterparts in the movie but not that
much older i think they were only like
18
19 20 something like that so they so it
wasn't like 30 year olds playing high
school students
which i kind of got a lot of that late
90s teen
horror movies i kind of got that vibe
it's like that person is clearly not a
high school student
these two were actually closer in age to
actual high schools
even though they're supposedly 15 and 16
they're
really for the era they were acting more
like 17 and 18 year olds
yeah but that that scans because like i
feel like a lot of girls like you know
when i was in high school and like you
know friends of mine that were and you
know that's
going back like a decade before this but
we were kind of a little bit ahead a
little bit ahead because
you know we were really into you know
literature and we were all into this
kind of stuff so
so so yeah so i feel like they were like
a little more mature for their age i
also really like that they nailed
because like i said i saw this movie a
couple times like back in the day but i
hadn't seen it for many years
and watching it again a couple nights
ago i was like oh my god i forgot how
[ __ ]
funny this movie is yeah like the first
half especially like all the [ __ ]
with you know the [ __ ] in the school
their humor with each other
mimi rogers playing the mom oh my god
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] hilarious because
like the
the [ __ ] the cringey [ __ ] there bob says
about like [ __ ]
and when ginger like gets her period and
she like makes her a cake
and [ __ ] like that it was like oh my god
i was dying it was just
spot on for the time and like i tell you
i was already in my late
20s during that time but in our [ __ ]
extended
ring of [ __ ] goth friends some of
them were just like maybe
seniors in high school or maybe just got
out that's the way they were
they were like that and usually like the
older goths kind of took care of them
kept them out of trouble that was the
baby bag and
the baby bats you got ready you got
ready you got them ready for when they
hit 19. that was they were old enough to
get into the club
yeah so that's so you were kind of
schooling them
[Laughter]
for like a year or two until they were
old enough you know what i mean it was
it was
it was a good time and it was very it
was the time of the early internet
and social media hadn't really kind of
taken its effect on people yet it was
just it was just a good time the scene
was
social media for us not some electronic
thing
not at that time yeah and like i said
you know there was a lot of stuff with
pen pals and like writing to magazines
yeah
like i was telling you my my ex-wife she
was big into those pen pal rings because
she was in
growing up in mississippi in an
environment like this and
there wasn't really an established
internet that's how goths met each other
yeah and it was just like people like
what the [ __ ] you talking about
it was a bunch of pieces of paper like
this and each one of them had
photographs and xerox things mostly
xerox photographs
and sayings and like profile of a person
written on a piece of paper and their
address
and you might had 30 of them and with a
hole going through it and it's all
ring with a string going through it and
you would
go through there and see the people that
you like to get all their addresses and
start writing them
then you took the the uh
the ring and you mailed that to
somebody in somebody else another goth
and then they went through it
and they'd pass it around and sometimes
it had gifts on it
it was another [ __ ] time like a chain
letter like a chain letter
but not a shitty one yeah no it was all
like handmade little
profiles someone would be made out of
leather somebody made out of cloth with
[ __ ] cool [ __ ] on it
it was just a there's a time when you
made things by hand it's like something
off of etsy
yeah yeah it was all like gothed out and
those are around for probably five or
six years
yeah and then we had fan zines which
were local magazines that you made on a
repediograph type thing
yeah with your friends on it and then
you got other people involved in it
and you just gave them out for free you
handed them out for the club yeah
usually as you did
yeah and people contributed maybe
they'll make a whole page and then you
go yeah okay you copy that and
copy that off on a repediograph and
they're around ever you know and some of
the [ __ ] got wild you know what i mean
they're [ __ ] you look and there's
like
basically like a couple pages of maybe
like nudes or
soft core kind of porn with some goth
girls in the local area you know you
know who that is
they're dressed up in outfits you know
really wasn't real sex they're just
simulated type
yeah stuff you know vampire lesbian
vampire makeout
shootout lesbian vampire make out
uh what do you call them uh photo shoots
and [ __ ]
in the damn fantasy yeah yeah [ __ ]
another time
yeah it was but yeah so um so yeah i
have to say too that i really really
like
the opening credits of this movie i
think we uh mentioned it before but
these two girls who are sisters they are
kind of like i mean they're the weirdos
at school
um this takes place in a fictional town
called bailey downs
they never tell you that it's canada but
it is canada yeah i saw that
neighborhood number like where the [ __ ]
is that yeah it's it's scary they don't
have
neighborhoods that look like that yeah
they can't i can't remember the name
they use like three different suburbs
like in canada might have been ontario
or southern
southern ontario or something like that
like something in england or something
where they filmed it
and um yeah so so it's but it's a
fictional town
so these two get picked on in school a
lot you know as they would because
they're
weirdos and freaks and they're like all
death obsessed and stuff yeah you all
have it easy it was hard when we were
doing it it was yeah so
like yeah so i so i could relate to
these characters and
um so they kind of just have you know
and they're very close in age and they
have
you know interests you know in common so
the two sisters basically are like if we
don't get out of this town by the time
we're both 16
then we're gonna kill ourselves they
have like a suicide pact whether they're
really gonna do it or not i don't know
they were [ __ ]
yeah probably but it's like but what
they're doing they're working on a
school project where they're like taking
all these pictures of themselves like in
simulated death things and there's and i
love that they show all the photos like
during the opening credits like you know
there's
my favorite one is the one where jinger
is laying on the grass and there's like
a lawn mower laying on top of her and
there's like [ __ ] intestines
yeah i never it's so awesome i never
actually saw anybody do that in the
scene but
similar i saw that looks like yeah
actually i did see that but that was
like
big city goths doing that kind of [ __ ]
well who had the money and
expertise to do the special effects yeah
because it was pretty cool like the
special effects
yeah yeah so definitely so you had that
which gave me a little bit of a herald
and mod vibe
because i feel like harold in that movie
was always like staging suicides like
for the benefit of his mom
but she was kind of over it so kind of
the same thing was going on here they
were doing this project with all these
death photos
and their mom was just kind of like oh
you know there's the kids with their
death photos again
we were always doing [ __ ] like going to
the graveyards and doing [ __ ]
photo shoots out there like rising from
the grave or
[ __ ] photo shoots of like you're
doing tarot cards and stuff it was just
another time
yeah it was yeah um but yeah so
basically these two girls now
uh unusually and especially i guess
unusually for nowadays
um neither of these two girls despite
being 15 and 16 have had their period
yet like i said it's not super weird it
does happen
um but it's almost kind of like they
don't want to get their period because
they don't want to be adults
they don't want to like have this
responsibility i guess or they you know
they they just kind of want to stay
with each other and they don't want to
like go they don't want to run off with
boys and they don't want to my
interpretation was is that they really
weren't
into [ __ ] boys yet they were too shy
about it
yeah that's what i'm saying so they
didn't really and and they were so that
changes though
right yeah but they were so bullied that
they only had each other
so they were just kind of like you know
you can't leave me for some dude
you know that's like a betrayal which is
kind of which is the way that a teenage
girl would think the girls didn't like
them but the guys were starting to check
them out they're like
that one of them they started to focus
in on the redhead well after she got
after she started like wolfing out yeah
maybe before that remember she
she period was coming and she was like
her back was hurting and the guys were
watching and she goes she got a nice rag
yeah that's true so they were kind of
like because she was kind of wearing
frumpy clothes yeah
they're like she's looking pretty good
she he tried to make a move on her but
he did the [ __ ] wrong
that's right well that was i love that
scene too because like i said this is
one of the scenes where i was like i
forgot how [ __ ] funny this movie is
the guy just basically came up and what
did he see he says something like
hey when are we gonna hook up hey we
should he didn't say hook up he said we
should get together or we should be
together or something like that
and she just looks at him and goes no
it was kind of working her the hormones
were calling her
the hormones were calling her but his
approach was too
positive and optimistic he was
approaching her like maybe like he he
was approaching her in the way
[ __ ] football jack which wasn't he
was yeah he was kind of what a popular
kid
would approach a [ __ ] cheerleader
yeah that's what he was doing
like hey it's like i've chosen you let's
go no i wouldn't
say hey how are you doing that's what it
seems like i've chosen you i've chosen
you let's go out we should be together
we should hang out together i've chosen
you and yeah yeah basically
yay yeah he did like her though
she was thinking about it but she's like
nah
that's not how you approach goth girls
didn't do it back then
that's not how you did that [ __ ] back
then well and the thing too
is that being it being in the gas
station and being like having these kind
of
uh normal people come to the goth bars
and they would try to pick you up
because they have they don't know how to
act because they have a weird
fetish i guess like for goth chicks and
they think like you're into this weird
freaky [ __ ] and they're just like oh i'm
gonna try that out
and it's like they don't understand that
we've had that happen like
like for years and years like millions
of times back in those days [ __ ]
goth god's met other gospel i've gone
those are some fantastic
shoes god those shoes are awesome either
that or
either that or you had like a really
cool band shirt on yeah they were really
it couldn't be a lie it had to be true
yeah now i like those shoes
[Laughter]
because usually that was the most
expensive thing a goth girl had on with
shoes
yeah and they saved up for like a really
long time either that or corsets you can
get cheap courses nowadays but back in
the day they were really expensive
depending on where you met her
in a club she might have a corset but if
you just met her around at school or
something like that yeah not that many
people were
just horses at school because it would
just be shoes the
daytime me encounter would be like shoes
yeah she says i like your shoes
because then she knew that you knew you
knew the deal yeah yeah
yeah she's like yeah these are my
neurons and if you were to cost 400.
yeah if you were if you were already
dressed up sometimes you could say that
[ __ ]
because if because you're wearing your
[ __ ] you had the right to see that [ __ ]
there's some good shoes she goes yeah
yeah yeah thanks yeah
you're looking good you know it wasn't
as long as they were on the same level
as long as you were on the same level
with that girl it wasn't hard and like i
said as long as you weren't like making
it like she was just
you weren't it wasn't a fetish like it's
like oh i'm gonna get like i'm going to
teach these people how to pick up god's
girls man well it's too late now you
already know what it did
well you had you had to be a goth if you
if you were a goth and you were a good
one
yeah it wouldn't work it wouldn't work
if you were just like some
no jack looking [ __ ] that
wouldn't work now they had their
defenses up for that
yeah big time still do um but yeah so
these two sisters like i said they
haven't had their periods yet but jinger
starts getting that
that back pain and that's another really
funny scene where they're all around the
dinner table and like she's like she's
like god damn and it's like
the mom's like where is the pain at it
is it right here and
she's like yeah i guess and she's like
you're getting your period yay and then
like the dad is over there just kind of
going like i'm eating oh my god and it's
like
that's one of the things that cracks me
up about this because i feel like a lot
of
movies they don't really talk about
you know girls periods and it's just f
it's very very funny to me when they do
when they talk about it really
matter-of-factly in a movie and at how
uncomfortable
it makes people and they're also kind of
like making a joke about somebody about
that
dad being like really uncomfortable
about it and [ __ ] but even the girls
themselves are kind of uncomfortable
about it because they go to like the
[ __ ]
you know after ginger gets her period
and then gets bit by the werewolf
in what is actually a very good and well
edited scene they don't show the
werewolf too much it's just kind of like
drags her around and like
chops her up or you know scratches her
and bites her and stuff
and when she starts wolfing out she
doesn't want to believe it
so she thinks that it's all having to do
with the period because she's like oh
i'm growing hair
like this coarse hair out of this like
cuts on her
shoulder and stuff and um so
the sister bridget like pretty much
immediately knows that it's got to be a
werewolf but ginger doesn't believe it
so she goes to the school nurse's office
and like the school nurse is just like
talking about the periods like talking
about how they work and everything like
that
and the two girls are just like they're
like mortified and it's just like so so
funny to me
but yeah so um so jinger
like i said she doesn't really believe
she's turning into a werewolf but
bridget does
and i think this is cool too like
bridget actually has
a an ally in the form of this dude named
sam who i guess he's like older he
because he goes out with that school
bully girl who i think
uh her name's trina in the movie like
that [ __ ] girl
and he's like the the drug dealer like
the school drug dealer
and he actually hits the werewolf with
his car
like shortly after it bites ginger and
he
is pretty sure that it's a werewolf like
not only because it kind of looks like a
big
wolf which obviously they don't have
around there but also he notices that
the penis of the werewolf is circumcised
yeah that's funny so i was like i
thought that was a nice touch
that like that that's how he lifting a
circumcised that was a man
yeah that's how he knew it was a
werewolf crazy photos we used to take
back then that was from that time that
was me from that time
yeah there you go that's the kind of
[ __ ] we used to do and they named barry
newman
yeah and they talked about this kind of
stuff it was just
very it was just accurate for the time i
mean
that's the way the girls looked back
then
and the way they show the
the werewolves it's the same way so i
just liked that era
yeah fashion and they got it right
yeah because like they they weren't you
know they weren't super dressed up or
anything but obviously they
because they weren't old enough to go to
clubs they were just going to school
yeah a lot of it was just like that yeah
and that's the way that's the way it
looked
so yeah so i really like that they did
that with the werewolf so so bridgette
has this kind of older guy who
believes her and they're basically like
well we need to do something about this
because prior to this like from the very
beginning of the movie
there has been a werewolf running around
which is nobody knows it's a werewolf
obviously but they're calling it the
beast of bailly downs
and so far it's just been killing
people's dogs um and by the way
if you were a dog lover and you don't
want to see a bunch of dogs like
horribly
mauled you probably don't want to watch
this movie because
you don't see it happening but you see
the aftermath and the aftermath is
pretty gnarly like a lot of dogs
it's not real no it's not real but a lot
of dogs like
you know fake get all [ __ ] up and
messed up and it's pretty like gross
looking
so the effects are really good but like
i said if you're real sensitive about
that you might not want to watch this
movie because a lot of dogs get killed
but um yeah so basically so he hits that
werewolf like i said the werewolf has a
dick so the two of them kind of get
together now at first
bridget tells him that it's her that's
turning into a werewolf because i guess
she wants to protect her sister
however sam is not really a dummy and he
eventually by the time that they figure
out that monks hood which is kind of
like a variation
of wolf's banner is like a relative of
wool spain um
but he says it's not as toxic in small
doses which
i'm not sure that's the case i'm not a
pharmacologist or anything but i think
that monks foot is also toxic
so don't be drinking that like to carry
yourself a werewolf rage just to protest
but um yeah so it works for the movie
though because it's like a scientific
type of thing there's no magic or
anything
yeah and the guy that's doing this is
kind of if you ask me he's kind of like
a stand-in christian slater he was kind
of reminded he looks a lot like
christian slater yeah and i think he was
in
um maybe some of this director's other
movies john fawcett directed it by the
way
who actually went on to do uh the very
popular british tv show orphan black
so sam figures out that it's actually
ginger that's the werewolf because she
has uh obviously very obviously started
to act very differently
uh she started growing a tail she's
gotten really sexually voracious like
the one guy she said no to earlier i
think his character's name is jason
like they go out on a date and basically
she just like jumps on him and like
scratches them all
up and [ __ ] yeah he's bragging about all
the scratches i know which is like it's
funny because like at the time they're
like
you know humping in the back of the car
and she gets all mad because he's like
she wants to get on top and he's like
wait who's the man here and she's like
who's the man here bam i'm just like
and she like tears his ass off she gets
real strong evidently
but the actress probably weighs 100
pounds she's a tiny tiny tiny woman
yeah she's real little yeah she is very
very very
small i couldn't and actually i couldn't
even believe it like when she walks down
the hall the first time like
after she got her period and the
werewolfy thing and she walks down the
hall at school
like wearing kind of sexier clothes yeah
and everybody's starting to look at her
yeah um i was like oh my god i can't
believe how small that
that girl is she's [ __ ] time she
looks great though that that kind of she
did
that kind of build looks really good in
clothing actually that type of clothing
that she had on
you know yeah it's not that full figure
[ __ ] porn star
[ __ ] look but as far as modeling
clothing
that's that's that that's a really good
build
yeah for that but yeah she's super super
small but yeah um
uh it goes on that ginger um you think
that she killed jason
like during the the date where she tore
his ass up and everything
uh but it turned out that she just
killed the neighbor's dog however she
does end up killing trina later on
and i can't say i feel too bad about
that because trina was kind of a taunt
she infected him though she infected him
yeah and uh he's
you know he didn't take it too well uh
no broke out a bunch of zits and started
acting like a psycho
and started peeing blood yeah yeah he
didn't know what was going on
my pen exploded my red pen yeah
he started to like grow a tail he he
knew something was wrong by the end but
he got killed i think didn't he no he
did not uh what ended up happening with
that is
remember that bridgette and sam had you
know
had the syringe with the monkeys yeah
yeah yeah that's right the sheets
and she was going home to try it out on
ginger
because she had locked ginger up however
ginger had escaped when she was going
back out she ran into jason so she
said oh i'll try this out on him
beforehand so i know that if it's going
to work or not and it seemed to work
they didn't really well that's what's
kind of interesting is they left that
kind of open-ended like you assumed that
it worked because she put it in his neck
and then he and then he seemed to like
act normal again and he's like yeah i
gotta go to class or whatever
but then as it goes on she never does
she's gonna give it to ginger
and then there's like all this other
stuff like i said ginger kills like a
couple other people
and bridget to get ginger to come back
to the house with her so she can
administer the rest of the
of the cure she actually like cuts her
hand open and like
mixes her blood with her she's like look
i'm a werewolf too now you have to come
with me like now we're together forever
just like we said we were gonna be
so but then like sam kind of [ __ ] it up
because then he hits ginger in the head
with a shovel and she's like you dumbass
it's like you know i was
you know i did that to like get her back
to the house because i had more stuff at
the house
but she doesn't end up taking it so what
ends up happening at the end and like i
said if you just came out in 2000 this
was 20 years ago if you haven't seen it
spoiler alert you know sorry but
you know what i'm saying so what ends up
happening at the end is that sam
gets killed because he's like well i'm
gonna go you know give her the cure but
you know ginger is not having that and
at this point jinger is like full-on
werewolf and she looks like and like i
said i like that the werewolf design
you can tell this was a lower budget
movie um but the werewolf still looks
pretty good
i like the one out of werewolf in london
in the end it's kind of broad
down yeah but not furry not furry no
it's almost kind of like they made it
like not furry which i thought was kind
of an interesting
it's like a it's like a wool it's like a
a human shaped more like a wolf
but no not hair not yeah it's weird
because some of the close-ups that they
used i think were a puppet but i think
that one was i mean that one was a
puppet too but i think it was like
puppeteered whereas like i think they're
one of the better i actually
think i kind of would have preferred a
wolf like something out of uh out of
uh [ __ ] how like something stood up
right but
that's this is what they chose to do
well that's yeah that's what i mean you
can't
you know i i know that a lot of werewolf
movies they have like a stand-up
werewolf because i guess that's just
like easy
easier to do but you know i think the
werewolf in this looks pretty good
and like i said i like the fact that
they kept it from looking like a girly
werewolf it just looks like a wolf
because like i said or it looks like a
werewolf would look
you can't really tell if it's a male or
female because like i said wolves you
can't tell by looking at them if they're
male or female so you know
that's what kind of what they did so she
ends up uh you know killing sam
and then at the end when their her and
bridget are fighting
and bridget ends up stabbing her to
death
and just kind of lays there while ginger
dies
now that and that's the end now you were
led to assume
you know again that after the
movie ended that bridgette took the cure
because she had also
you know taken ginger's blood and was
presumably going to turn into a werewolf
in her turn so you presume that that's
what happened
like after the events of the movie
although like i said in the sequel
it turns out that the monks hood worked
but it was only temporary or it didn't
work all the way or something like that
so she had to like do some other [ __ ]
like i said i haven't seen the second
one i just kind of like read the plot
synopsis or i heard somebody else
talking about it
so they do kind of like clear that up
one interesting thing that i wish
because i really really love this movie
i think it's really good
easily like you know if you're talking
about like best werewolf movies
yay gonna be like you know the howling
american werewolf in london dog soldiers
all that kind of stuff um but i think
this is definitely up there it's really
really well done
and it's one of the very few that has a
female werewolf in it which i thought
was really cool i really liked the whole
puberty is werewolf transformation thing
they did a lot of funny gags with that
like at the beginning and like i said i
forgot how [ __ ] funny this
movie was the two girls that were in it
were the
chemistry with them was great they
actually seemed like actual sisters like
the way they talk to each other
soundtrack
soundtrack and music and stuff yeah i
mean all your late 90s early 2000s goth
well you sort of goth metal it was
industrial in there too yeah
i mean it's it's a solid flick all
around uh it's a testament
to that era uh and it's not a real big
budget movie
but it does it did capture the feeling
of the time it just did to me
yeah i felt like i was going back in
time going yeah that's it
the only thing i would ding it on is i
think the third act drags slightly
just lightly um and also i don't like
that they left
the subplot with the mom open-ended yeah
because i think what happened like
when they do when they kill trina they
don't actually kill her on purpose
necessarily like her and ginger are
fighting and then trina like falls in
the kitchen and like busts her head open
on the
side of the cabinet and i love that the
parents are coming home so they have to
like pretend this is another death scene
that they've done
and the mom is just kind of like oh you
kids clean that all up
or whatever and then they have like the
body in the freezer
and uh they break the fingers off while
they're trying to get the body out
you're right there are there were some
parts in this movie
where the edit isn't real tight it gets
a little bit muddy but it doesn't ruin
the flick it's still
no like i said not at all that was and
that's a very very minor nitpick
um and like i said so there's like an
interesting thing where the mom
uh played by mimi rogers as i mentioned
who is
who is delightful in this she's like
she's
in some of the best like funniest scenes
just her reactions to [ __ ] are funny
now the interesting thing about her
character is she finds
trina's body which they have buried like
in their
backyard like in the shed or something
like that it's underneath that house
yeah like underneath
their old playhouse or whatever so she
finds the body
and her first instinct is i'm gonna
protect my two daughters no matter what
i'm gonna burn the house down and we're
gonna take off
you know what i mean and she's just
totally serious about it and you know
bridget's like what about dad and she
like doesn't even say anything about it
kind of just like [ __ ] him i suppose
well because the dad character is kind
of like not present which i guess was
sort of like
really seem to care about him too much
anyway he was kind of kind of a douche
really he was a douche
he wasn't a dick it was just like he was
like well he was very neglectful
it didn't really matter he seemed like
he didn't really care that much about
what was going on and you know all that
other kind of stuff so you can always
no there was a backstory he had a
girlfriend you know he didn't really
give a [ __ ] yeah because he seemed like
he wasn't really like
as annoying as her character was like
but she was meant to be annoying like
this kind of helicopter
parent who was trying to be a cool
parent like you can talk to me about
anything you talked to me about
boys and your period and all this other
kind of stuff and then the girls were
just like mortified by her presence so
she was like a little try hard
but her heart was in the right place and
i feel like she had a lot of
issues and they don't really go into it
but you can tell like
just later on in a couple of lines like
that when she says stuff to the dad
that she's kind of like feels like she
has to do this all by herself like the
dad is sort of checked out
so you can see at the end where she's
just basically like i'm gonna blow the
whole house up and me and my daughter's
just gonna run off and change our
identity or whatever
and that's kind of like the last time
you see her is when she's sitting in the
car and uh
bridgette goes in to get ginger from the
party so she can give her the cure and
then you don't see the mom again like
she just kind of goes to the party and
bridgette takes off and ditches her
knowing how it went my generation a lot
of times you know
as soon as the kids were out of high
school the parents divorced
yeah they were just waiting out of the
house so i can get risks
i'm sick of it yeah and that's like
my parents divorced before that you know
yeah
my parents were 14. the kids that i was
graduating through high school with as
soon as the [ __ ] their graduations
went down
their parents split up yeah okay
as soon as all the kids are old enough
they because they got married young
anyway
yeah baby boomers did so that's what
they were talking about i think in this
movie
yeah like i said they don't get super
into it because i think the dad is only
in like
two or three seconds i think i think the
parents were just together for the time
being
yeah until until the kids were out of
high school yeah so i kind of wish that
they had followed up on that just a
little maybe they did in the sequel i'm
not really sure
um but like what happened with the mom
you know what i mean like what happened
when she got home
and found bridget with this [ __ ] dead
werewolf
that used to be ginger like i so i guess
that's a sign of a good movie because
you're wondering like what happened like
after the credits rolled like what
happened
these people like what was the mom's
reaction to that [ __ ] because i would
have loved to seeing that
but yeah that's like i said that's a
minor minor nitpick that they just kind
of
you know left that dangling um but other
than that
i really really like this movie and like
i said one of the very few female
werewolf movies which i think is really
cool
uh i found out that they are actually as
of
october which is only a couple months
ago
um they're talking about making a series
out of this
so we'll see how that goes yeah it
actually might make a good series i like
because i like the
mythology that they use with the more
scientific thing of the werewolf they
don't explain where the first werewolf
came from
but you know the stuff about the monks
hood and
you know you know being a cure and maybe
not working as well
so i feel like there's a lot you could
do with that i would be interested in
seeing the series i think the series
would be better if it was back in the
90s or the [ __ ] two things i'm kind
of hoping they said it back then because
that's before social media and cell
phones i mean they had them but not
only rich people had cell phones um
during that era well not rich people i
guess well they were just not really
they just weren't widespread they were
still expensive yeah yeah they were
big it just really wasn't worth it kids
didn't have them
um i think it would be better if it's in
modern times it probably
i don't know yeah the appeal of this
movie a big part of it is the era
is the era that it was made yeah and i
do feel like
well that's the thing i do feel like
when they've remade properties like that
i think the shitty ones are the ones
where they try to update it but the best
ones i think are the ones where they
kind of set it in the same era
and as i said i think lately it's just
easier
i guess it's not easier from a
production design standpoint but it's
easier
to write a horror movie in wedding days
in olden days when you don't have the
access to
gps and cell phones and you don't have
all this stuff that you can fall back on
yeah you know what i'm saying no
internet yeah no internet no anything
like that so i think it makes things
like a lot more complicated so that's i
think that's why you see a lot of horror
movies made nowadays that are set
back in that era the late 90s early
2000s was just you know for you
youngsters man i'll call you all
youngsters for you youngsters
whippersnappers
different era totally different i mean
uh you were just very low information
which in some ways there was a lot more
mystery in life
you had you really had to work hard to
find information so it was more
rewarding when you found it but you were
mostly you know researching something on
the internet we had back then you
weren't going to find it it was going to
be something in books
yeah and you know books were [ __ ]
expensive and big and had to go to the
library or you had to order one and and
then it was kind of the book was kind of
out of date anyway so you know
that the flow of information was slower
back then and less
there's a lot of misinformation now
online but at least it's coming faster
and you can whittle it down to what you
think probably more what happened or
what the right thing to do is
not that not back then you had to kind
of rely on friends and instinct and
intuition which is that it's like well i
read this thing in this book so it must
be true but it's like there was no way
you'd have to like stumble across
they're like no that's actually not true
like in some other book that you happen
to read
and you had to ask like one of the one
of your older trusted friends what do we
do with this and he did well let me see
and that was the position i was in back
in those days you know you'd have again
teenage you know teenage people and 18
19 year olds
19 years old tom what do we do about
this and that and i'm [ __ ] going han
solo
you never wanna no no i'm [ __ ] 27 28
i'm sounding wise as [ __ ]
you know well two nowadays they just go
online and look
yeah everybody just looks up just look
it up online so like i said it makes
things a lot easier
right and it put in a horror movie in
modern days
it can be done it's been done i've seen
a lot of really good
you know horror movies set now but it's
best in
outer space where you're isolated where
you have technology but you
can't call for help because you're in
outer [ __ ] yeah i feel like
[ __ ] like that it depends depends on
what kind of horror movie you're making
but i do feel like nowadays they always
have to come up with some id
like they have to come up with some
excuse why people can't use their cell
phones or they can't use the internet
like oh there's a blizzard and you know
everything's out
or you're in an underground or yeah
you're out in the middle of nowhere
where there's no wi-fi or something like
that there always has to be some
reason why you can't use it yeah because
it just makes everything so yeah you
can't set this in a suburb
now so every suburb and every person has
a [ __ ] cell phone
yeah and like you would know and if
there was a werewolf running around a
suburb like this everyone would know
like immediately
because everyone would film it yeah
everyone film it and you'd know what to
do about the werewolf because you just
google the [ __ ]
yeah they kill werewolf
[Laughter]
although i think even now like even back
then people knew that kind of [ __ ]
you got zombie movies where they don't
even know they don't even know to call
them zombies
see that that bothers me i'm like
everybody knows what it is
you have to figure out how to shoot him
in the head to kill him yeah it's like
every movie it's like do we really have
to go through this again
everybody knows how to kill a zombie by
now come on that's why if you're gonna
do that
set the movie back in like the 1800s or
something
when people actually didn't know what
zombies were right
all right so uh anyway if you have not
seen ginger snaps which like i said is
very hard for me to believe uh it's
actually [ __ ] i didn't see it
that's true you hadn't seen it i didn't
see it but you're not like a horror dork
like a lot of yeah
i was busy at this time man we're
[ __ ] new orleans in new orleans
[ __ ] partying and [ __ ] man we were
making movies like this happen in real
life
in the goth scene down crystal [ __ ]
crystal in the [ __ ]
man never mind crystal in the convent
but yeah so if you want to watch it it's
on
shutter in the u.s and i think it's also
on to be
if i'm not mistaken so if you want to
watch it for free but yeah it's a good
movie like i said good special effects
good characters
and you know it's just a fun funny movie
all around
so uh we'll see you on the next movie
retrospective
bye